yes we're here tonight to honor and
hopefully arrest a man who was great in
two things 25 years ago Charlie Sheen
actually there's a lot of Sheen on TV
this evening when the show airs tonight
on Two and a Half Men they're actually
having Charlie's pretend funeral believe
it or not you there's no need to switch
over though just wait a few months you
can probably see the real thing
[Applause]
I mean we all know there's a good chance
Charlie will be dead soon so I wrote a
know an obituary Charlie Sheen who
became a tabloid fixture due to his
problems with drugs and alcohol was
found dead in his apartment actually no
what I kinda actually just copied Amy
Winehouse's obituary it's it's I only
had to change three things though the
sex of the deceased the location of the
body and the part that says a talent
that will be missed